Continuing in al-wajeez
in the book of fasting at the very tail
end of the book of fasting.
We had just concluded the chapter
regarding the days which are prohibited
which a person is prohibited from
fasting.
And the author mentions them from most
strong in prohibition.
And he mentioned seven of them. Can we
name those seven?
What do you think?
What's the first one?
The days of Eid.
The days of Tashreeq.
Friday alone.
Saturday alone.
Fasting every day, so the entire year.
Okay, even if a person
avoids those previously mentioned days.
Okay, that's five.
What's that?
Yeah, the second half of Sha'ban and one
more.
No, he mentioned that.
It has to do with Ramadan.
Yawm ash-shakk.
Not necessarily the day before.
Remember, got to be precise.
The day of doubt.
Why is it the day of doubt? We have not
seen a clear sign
that Ramadan has commenced.
But we haven't really seen a clear sign
that it hasn't commenced.
It's overcast. The moon could have been
there, could not have been there.
If it's overcast, the prophet tells us
salallahu alayhi wasallam,
if it's overcast,
continue in Sha'ban.
Right? Because the month of Ramadan, or
any month for that matter, can only
commence
or can only be
you know, believed to have commenced in
one of two ways.
Either clear sighting of the crescent
or 30 days of of the previous month.
Those are the only two ways.
And so,
if it's overcast, we could have seen the
moon, we could not have seen the moon.
Who knows what's up there? And so, this
is the day of ash-shakk. Person says,
"Well, you know what? Let me just go
ahead and cover my bases, right?
Just make sure."
This here is prohibited. It's prohibited
for a number of reasons.
but one of the most important of
those reasons is that
it either is Ramadan or it is not.
There's no such thing as it might be
Ramadan, it might be Sha'ban, and Allah
will hold me accountable if I don't
somehow cover both of those.
This is not how
the months in Islam work.
The final thing that the author mentions
with regards to fasting, and then after
that he will mention a very short
chapter regarding I'tikaf, which
traditionally the scholars of fiqh will
place the chapters or the book of
I'tikaf right after
the book of fasting, or sometimes right
before the book of fasting. but it is
usually associated with fasting. And
that is because many scholars, first of
all, view that there is no I'tikaf
without fasting. That is an opinion.
And secondly, they are very
closely related due to the fact that
al-I'tikaf usually takes place in
Ramadan.
So, the last thing that the author
mentions in this
book of fasting, he says,
This one is going to make some
make some people upset, right? This is
going to ruffle
what do they say?
This is going to ruffle some feathers,
right? And that is
the prohibition
of a woman fasting without the
permission of her husband if he is
present. Meaning, if he's not traveling,
if he is around.
Why is that? Why is it prohibited for a
woman to fast without her husband's
permission?
of course, this is optional fasting,
right?
Because obedience to her husband is
obligatory, and fasting is preferred.
And a husband may desire that of his
wife, which would entail her breaking
her fast.
Person may say, "Well, what's the
problem? You know, if
if that,
you know, if it comes to that, she could
break her fast." However, this would
place the husband in a
position of
you know, discomfort that he is now
interrupting his wife from the
worship of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so, when a woman has general or
specific permission from her husband to
fast, general permission meaning they
have an agreement. She always fasts
Mondays and Thursdays. She always fasts
the three days of the month. She has
some kind of, you know, schedule that
she fasts on.
This is a generalized agreement or a
specific agreement.
I would to fast today. I'd to
fast next week. I'd to fast
tomorrow. Whatever it is.
This is critical
so as to maintain the balance
of harmony in the household, right?
[Silence]
He says on the authority of Abu Hurayrah
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
salallahu alayhi wasallam said, "No
woman is to fast whilst her ba'l
Her ba'l is another word used in Arabic
for husband.
But the word ba'l
in the Arabic language, when referring
to a husband, doesn't just articulate
that he is a husband or a spouse.
It articulates husband, and it
articulates superior. Someone who she is
required
her subordination is of requirement to.
This is referred to as a ba'l.
And this is the wording that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala uses in the Quran.
Sometimes he uses the word zawj,
which is just husband. Sometimes he uses
the word ba'l.
Sometimes he uses the word sayyid, which
is a master, right?
al-ba'l
originates in the Arabic language as the
male of the camels.
And camel husbandry,
the male camel that is used to
impregnate the she-camels and is
often viewed as a superior camel, a
camel that is
more expensive, a camel that is capable
of breeding, right? So, the Arabs would
refer to this camel as a ba'l. So, that
is superimposed from that onto a husband
in the
language of the Arabs. And this is
one of the terms that Allah uses in the
Quran to refer to the husband. He says,
[Arabic recitation]
fee dhalik." And usually this word is
used in the Quran when
that superiority and when we say
superiority, we're not saying that
all men are better than all women. This
isn't what is meant. When we say
superior, we mean the
counter to not not superior
as opposed to inferior. We're saying
superior in a as opposed to subordinate.
Right?
Superior as opposed to subordinate.
you would have your superior at
your work, or your superior officer in
the military. Someone that you are
required
to
subord- to to provide subordination to,
someone whom you are a subordinate to.
This is what we mean by superior. And
the word ba'al articulates that meaning.
That is why it's used in the Quran in
that context, and that is why it is used
in this narration in this context. So,
he says, "No woman is to fast, or a
woman is not to fast whilst her ba'al is
present without his permission, or
except by his permission." And this
narration has been collected by both
Bukhari Bukhari and Muslim.
So, inshallah ta'ala, tomorrow we will
speak about the rulings of al-i'tikaf.
Is al-i'tikaf only in Ramadan? Is it
only permissible in Ramadan?
These are good questions.
Did the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam ever make i'tikaf outside of
Ramadan?
the answer is yes, he did. And we'll
read about that.
[Arabic recitation]
Nas'al Allah subhanahu wa
an yu'allimana wa an yanfa'ana wa an
yanfa'ana bima 'allamana
wa an yazidana 'ilman wallahu a'lam wa
sallallahu wasallam 'ala nabiyyina
[Arabic recitation]